our next presenter is Aaron Weis and
Aaron has given us the title from
complexity to the Clinic patient based
models of Time series gene expression in
every cell of your body you have 46
chromosomes containing 3 billion base
pairs of information carrying DNA this
DNA encodes 20,000 genes these genes
become proteins and proteins do
everything yourself into function what
genes are active and at what times is
controlled by 2,000 transcription
factors through a process called gene
expression regulation in a system with
this much complexity many things can go
wrong but unfortunately they often do in
some diseases such as sickle cell anemia
and Huntington's a change in a single
gene causes a single miss folded protein
defense will characterize disease state
in other diseases things are more
complicated for example in cancer the
syndrome that we've seen is a result of
hundreds of mutations acted in concert
bus genetics becomes genomics learner I
understand these diseases we have to
understand how the system has been
perturbed as a whole the and eventual
goal is the development of genomic
medicine drugs which can take this
perturb to gene expression state and
somehow recapture the normal state my
research fits into this and that I
attempt to understand how the gene
expression of diseased individuals
differs from that of normal individuals
here's how it works measure that you're
a patient and you go to the doctor what
do you do the doctor takes in a blood
sample using the experiment called
microwave we can get a reading of all
the expression levels of the genes in
your body we do this for each patient
every time he goes to the doctor we
should also do this for a whole cohort
with patients with the same disease once
we have this data we can build
mathematical models say one model for a
healthcare group of patients
one model for a sicker group of patients
and with this with these models we can
actually figure out which genes are
active in the disease and hence which
transcription factors are causing genes
to be accurate
once we've built these two models we can
look to see how they're different uses
statistical tests transcription factors
that are active in
one model not the other might be
interesting potentially as markers which
can be used for Diagnostics or in the
future as potential drug targets in the
moment
currently we are applying this technique
to real human patient data a set of
patients with idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis which is a lung disorder
currently our method is able to
determine which patients are more
healthy as well as which patients are
less healthy in addition to identifying
transcription factors that might be
causative with this and as this research
progresses the hope is to take the gene
expression measurement and make it it
sit on a tool which should be used in
the clinic first for Diagnostics and
eventually for treatment thank you